shei and Irving joins us good morning
che morning Danny yeah morning yeah not
good morning it's just morning morning
Sun came up I suppose I'd seen a good
how bad did it get yesterday thank you
it's almost like you know when you go to
rehab Danny I have met Ellaria rehab
well just give a time when you go to
rehab they tell you insanity is doing
the same thing and expecting different
results
which never makes sense to me until I
thought about the Cowboys and this
entire offense is predicated on the run
game being established at the o-line
control on the line of scrimmage
everything's open up after the run games
establish dak needs the run game to be
an effective quarterback he's bouncing
wide-open passes off the turf Danny this
is a starting quarterback for the Dallas
Cowboys you can't be skipping stones and
think that this is gonna work out what
the hell was a front office thinking
getting rid of Dez and letting Jason
wouldn't retire and thinking that nobody
else aside down herds and a rookie need
to be brought in for it what the hell do
you do that to your offensive team you
know that Prescott ain't Aaron Rodgers
we all know that he needs more help and
it's a run game ain't there it's over
Danny it's a wrap see you and then you
got the Giants coming up and that's
gonna be a human form that's so cool
okay wait man
that's gonna be awesome swing blade
he'll do it to you a little more time
why not I think you got to choose don't
you beat the Cowboys why don't you move
on from the Cowboys why don't you just
get another druggable well that's not
funny Danny you know you sound like the
roommate right now so you can how come
every team you love do you like that
woman he's gonna pick a new team's any
like that from Irving Texas Danny aboard
into this I can't believe it's gotten
this bad but I can grant you build a job
I can I can grant you your emancipation
from from Texas never never do they put
me in the DI Artie
and I mean look at your pics over the
weekend Oklahoma State Minnesota
recover you know ain't care yeah I know
I know you went to and two and then you
had a push anything else I just don't
understand yeah just don't understand
office Danny but but you keep saying
that it's the same thing every week and
it's not gonna change this is even worse
though because they had success they had
the formula for success two years ago we
saw how it works what do you know you
run the day of all play action deck
looks great but if you make deck sit in
the pocket and pretend to be a
quarterback daddy ain't look what the
hell you know what I could do is I could
just play this in like seven weeks seven
weeks from now and it would be the same
thing it would just be a different team
that they lost to so you could actually
take you know what you could take a week
off give me more time for morning drink
how about that you're interrupting my
morning drinking anyway Danny but let me
relive this don't you have to go to a
job every Monday dick I think you're
sick other days too but I I know you
mate I'm here for you
you have my number on whatever you need
Thank You chef his Twitter his Twitter
account was on fire not literally but if
if he could have he would have set fire
to it every Monday yeah but I could play
that I could play that with the next
cowboy I lost I could just play what he
says cuz he said the same thing every
time they lose the ginger they don't
establish the run and run the ball yeah
dak is not you know a quarterback who
can throw the ball 30 times roommate's
not supporting them yeah yeah Rumi why
don't you pick a new team four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you
[Music]